I don't relish any of this and I really
wish we didn't have to do it and the
government isn't running to do this the
government is doing this because this is
a major problems
we are being forced to do it and I'll
tell you why we're being Foster it I
think with those children seeking to
cross the channel I think of the danger
that their lives are being put in the
evil people Smugglers and whose hands
their place and unless we are willing as
a government and as a country to take
tough action in relation to this the
numbers will keep on growing and more
people's lives will be put at risk
including the lives of young children
and I'm simply not willing to allow that
to happen